hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to subnautica now I
have my builder tool and it seems to be
dipping into the knight territory and I
don't know why I mean I know why I have
a sneaking suspicion why but what I need
to do is I am going to build a base that
for damn sure that's 100% what I'm gonna
be doing and also I'm gonna be hitting
up lifepod 8 now I know life pot 8 is
getting closer and closer to the ship
but oddly enough near the ship is where
I need to go because they added a whole
bunch of stuff near the ship so what I'm
going to do is I'm gonna play double
duty here and I'm going to go and build
my base right by the ship so that I can
salvage every thing that I need from
that area because there are new things
in the ship that I can access or maybe
not new things but definitely things
whoa hello cargo where did you come from
well it's a piece of the Aurora is there
anything here I can scan something
necessary oh my god hello hi god I hate
you I hate you so much
no apparently not okay so either way
that's interesting but over by the shift
there's some new locations at least for
thus cannibals that I need to do to get
the technology I need to continue and
apparently it's not night and I was just
fooling myself
oh yeah the sun's right there okay so
what I'm gonna be doing is here ice and
sharks hey all you [ __ ] anyway like
I've been trying to say I'm gonna go hit
up life pot eight I'm gonna see what's
going on in there I'm going to try to
see if there's any storage lockers cuz
preferably it's gonna stay daytime and
not be nighttime god damn and you fuckos
you in Norma died it's so much bigger
you're so much bigger that's not right
it don't look at me
oh you here look at me watch oh yeah
that's right you turn back oh my god
there's so much bigger we're by the
Aurora we're probably pretty close to
the entrance to the Aurora but I'm gonna
see about the like what
whoa whoa is that the life raft for the
pot is it the pot upside down what whoa
that's not right that's life pod four
but that's talking about life pod eight
what what the hell happened
hello this water I guess why is it
floating upside down
it's very storage in here god there's no
storage container here either this is a
health kit maker this there's nothing in
here at least I got water which is what
I needed like immediately I am nutrient
block wait did I drop that bills perfect
that dad yeah this is so weird why is it
floating upside down that's just it
this is the most bizarre thing of all
the things to go wrong why is this thing
upside down is that just a reflection of
the core the corporation that sent us
here their machinery is so faulty even
though we can make stuff appear
materialize assemble the atoms into
water can ever configuration we want
they couldn't get a life pod to float
right-side up and that's what happened
here this is ridiculous okay but
apparently life pod eight is reading
down there which might mean that it's
below the dip here so I got to get going
before nightfall comes unless it's
buried in the sand which it might me
yeah there's nothing here life pod eight
is not here and there's just life pod
four there what does that mean where is
life pod aid why is life pod four upside
down what the hell is happening here I'm
gonna go back over to the lifeboat and
see if there's a data pad anywhere in
there but I don't think there is whoa
that is a big crystal and that is it Oh
give me that give it
oh listen uh whoa okay that is a big-ass
crystal though I want to take a look at
that
oh [ __ ] so many noise and so many things
wants to kill me
alright so this one a BAM we've got that
okay so I'm gonna swing down you get it
can you get the Frick away I need to get
whatever the hell this is what is this
ah no no no it's a friggin inch crustal
yeah [ __ ] hell it's gigantic
30 seconds folks there's another one
over there like is this something that I
could maybe pick away at with the knife
holy [ __ ] it is that what is that what
what are these I mean these are lithium
crystals which are important yes but
what are the Giants oh [ __ ] breach
breach oh god am I gonna make it I
better make it don't get dark go into
the darkness
pesky all right so I'm gonna check this
again
I would think there would be a datapad
in here is this a whole lot of nothing
yeah there's there's nothing in here
there's nothing in the nooks there's
nothing in the crannies there's nothing
in the cracks nothing in the backs okay
night is falling which is bad because I
don't want to be exploring the Aurora in
the middle of the night but that's what
I gotta do it's not what I want to do
but it's what I gotta do but benefit
being there's probably plenty of food
I'm thinking those have got to be
resources and stuff possibly for the new
the suit I think it as an excavation
function and if it does that means
that's incredibly useful because there's
just doodles and oodles of materials
right here by the Aurora so this
actually is not a bad place to build a
base I've never even thought about it
before because I didn't want to be near
here for some reason one reason or
another but these are these are enormous
material deposits and even though there
are sand sharks and whatnot I could
probably navigate them and put my base
like you know maybe even right here this
seems like a good place where it's kind
of nestled he's the access to above whoo
this is nice I could have a front lawn
yeah heck yeah
let's go to places any all right lit
let's let's let's do you this I don't
have titanium cuz I'm an idiot
all right but I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna section it off I'm gonna
section it off with flare oh yeah do the
flippy thing yeah you almost got that
right
have us key what where'd it go oh it's
over there what try that again
caboose key Wow that is frickin bright
as Frick bruh okay so what I need to do
is it hi I need to get
titanium but there's no like individual
titanium deposits here it's all just
giant freaking bags of it and I don't
have a frickin I did not plan this out I
left all my titanium
in the thing I do not recall my my life
pod being this far away I think I've
gotten some drift
I don't like draft god damnit why are
you so far away
she's yeah I do not recall this being on
the oh well well there we go then I'm
out of power and now I'm just on my own
now and now it's night I have no friends
that sad Sancho don't late so Sachi I
don't like that I don't like just seeing
lights in the darkness oh hi oh yeah
this definitely wasn't here before god
damnit who keeps pushing my god damn oh
[ __ ] you got babies okay so there's
small ones yes which are the old size
and then there's definitely big ones and
you have moved I don't know why but
you've moved your moved y'all moved fire
I need moved to boobity boobity boobity
boobity boo ah okay so this is
interesting this is interesting I do not
have the required plan for a base I
literally don't I I just don't have that
I need to find that where the heck do I
find that I have to go exploring enough
that I can find a base because without
that I'm I'm not going anywhere
dehydration detected yeah okay I got it
thank you Karen I love you a lot I guess
so I've got a lot of work to do freaky
deaky freaky dick okay so I need
[ __ ] [ __ ] that and [ __ ] you and [ __ ]
everything about this so the easiest
place that I know to find a bass with
which I could scan to be able to do that
is probably gonna be the floating island
which if I'm not mistaken by my
navigational charts here is going to be
on the southern end of the Aurora also
what the hell is those lights oh you are
so huge why are you so huge I do not
understand why they felt that need to
make you bigger those light whoa hello
hi floating rocks where did you come
from and you don't seem to be floating
so well you seem to be sinking
incredibly is there something down there
is there something that I haven't seen
before
who's that oh it's a piece of the Aurora
how did you yes how did you get blown
all the way over here that's not normal
okay hang on I got a good get here whoa
[ __ ] you it's after me [ __ ] you dude
calm down not worth it not worth it bro
man I found the fleet yeah I got it I'm
on it I'm on it Karen wow they must
added more detail to the Aurora because
I don't remember that the bat-beam that
detail but either way I think the
floating island is down this way but
then again I don't a hundred percent
know exactly which way uh-oh there it is
okay I think that's it hang on if I
squint my eyes really tightly be able to
see the outline of an island in the
midst two mists of pandaria yeah this is
also gonna be good because I can get the
planter plans for the base while I'm
over here which means that I can scan
pretty much everything that I need and
just be able to do it that way it's
another thing I want to say about not
cheating is just it makes the experience
so much more immersive because it's so
easy to be like ah this is nothing I can
just get whatever I want but whenever I
have to actually legitimately try it
means that it's that much more invested
in what I'm doing it looky looky here
we've got scannable 'he's living wall Oh
from the inside I got you
and it did oh I see something in there
oh I see a creature in there he's
hoppity hippity hoppity exterior grow
bed which I don't think I'm gonna be
able to use but might as well get it I
think there's an interior grow bed up in
the top one up on the mountain
they're Chinese potato plant does that
mean we brought them here how's that an
alien life form called a Chinese potato
plant doesn't make any sense all right
might as well eat the marble melon
boosts tea yum yum yum not bad not bad
at all
never get there we go this is what we
needed we needed the multi-purpose room
to be able to do what we needed to do
and there's a potato pad in there then
I'm gonna take a look at BAM that's
actually nice like I really like that
feature the fact that you don't know how
to build a multi-purpose room right off
the bat so you're forced to explore
before you can even start to survive
outside your life pod it's all just
really good features I like the way
they're doing it this way because it
just makes it you have to go around you
have to explore you don't have what you
need to survive life actually
legitimately is a struggle so if I go in
here find something else what never mind
god I remember when I was just building
my giant crate here no don't need to
scan that something in there battery yes
please okay hell yeah hell yeah I don't
even know what the bulkhead would do is
that just gonna be doors in between
rooms maybe a structural stability thing
going on there yeah I don't think I can
get in there unless I can build a hatch
on to this oh hello hall totals log
all stalkers log captain's log five
weeks since our ship the do Gossie was
shot down I gave thanks that fate saw
fit to spare my son Bart and I from
death but my personal entourage were not
so destined the only other survivor was
Margaret Maeda
cut a cut-price mercenary with local
expertise where I reluctantly
commissioned for the journey we spent
days in the life pods rain beating on
the roof nothing but ocean on the
horizon just as we were losing hope the
weather cleared and we saw this island
floating we were saved we salvaged
salvaged the wreck down to its bare
bones and built this habitat from scrap
I sent Bart's study the alien plant life
put that expensive digit rating to good
use people can question didja training
in foreign technology all they like
Bart's biochem imprint already paid for
itself as I dictate this I'm eating
hydroponically grown potato salad
garnished with seeds that taste like
spicy orange peel our only problem is
maida I've caught her muttering the
islands too small to support us
indefinitely that the weather's going to
turn on us I say she's grown
superstitious every judgment she makes
assumes things go from bad to worse that
the only forward is a fight she thought
to make take in some context as a
species we've spent millennia learning
how to shackle nature to our will this
planet won't cause us any new problems
our one task now is to stay alive as
comfortably as possible until rescue
arrives in this part of space that could
be months or even years so this is
saying they were shot down before the
Aurora even got here because our ship is
not the de gauzy obviously so it's a
different ship entirely so what's - oh
this oh never mind this is just a way in
okay never mind okay I thought that was
impossible
let's see Bart I said no your life is
worth more than your vegetable patch I
forbid you to go out there in the storm
I stopped needing your permission when
the ship you were captaining sunk you
will stop needing my permission the day
I'm not your father
say chief chief what do you know how to
drain those grow breads out there of 40
tons of storm water or how to conjure
food from the air don't try to be clever
no one likes a clever mercenary I'm just
saying what's your boys life worth to
you today if next week you're going to
be Songer you start wondering what
tastes like let him go deal with the
plants son go deal with the plants Bart
torgul is no longer aboard the habitat
interfere with my family again and when
rescue arrives I will leave you here you
understand me
no rescue come in chief not in time and
no staying here either this rain keeps
falling and sooner or later this place
will be buried only choice we've got is
whether to get buried with it stay away
from my boy well I can see that she was
right in one way or another but man was
it what is it without with survival
situations and people not working
together like would you rather be tom
hanks stranded on this island completely
alone with no one else here or would you
rather just work together with the only
humans you've got left yeah okay well
I'm gonna make my way up to the tip-top
of the island and scan what I can
because I need that interior grow bed if
I'm gonna be able to get enough food to
survive me for the rest of this journey
hey Lou oh I forgot about the trees over
there I'm gonna come back no I think
there's trees up top so I should be able
to scan them later hey Dad
they made it a little harder to just
clamber up the side of a mountain herb
butter oh not that hard hey okay made it
almost there come on careful careful
is this like uh ah [ __ ] god damn it okay
we're back now is this like uh that
mercenaries private roost goddamn it
just get in the goddamn door get in the
get in the door there we go plant pot
two and clam pot one I'm gonna be able
to grow stuff inside without cheating
okay we got plant pot two which I don't
know what the difference between that
and plant pot one would be at least I
can get a chair in an observatory
it won't work chief there's nothing left
on the gauzy no building materials on
this island and my nose tells me the
weather's turning we're gonna have to
get our feet wet
this island is safe there are no
predators we can grow food why would we
abandon it your kid says we can't grow
enough not without more grow beds speak
up kid it's true the natural growth
rates are too slow to support three of
us indefinitely especially if the
weather gets worse all I'm saying is
oceans got us surrounded
no use hiding I've made my decision you
two want to forfeit your commissions
just to take a swim believe me I'm
thinking on it so this guy did not even
want to go in the ocean which I totally
understand
cuz the oh [ __ ] is [ __ ] gas but also
at the same time you're gonna have to go
in there to get the nor the resources
that you need to build so he did not
want to even leave which like is just
definite death I mean there's
possibility of death and then there's a
hundred percent definite death which
would be not going in the frickin ocean
that you could use to survive
nom-nom-nom-nom-nom at least they took
away the possibility of those things
giving you damage okay so I don't think
there's anything left to scan there I
should be okay and then I'm just gonna
make my way to the other one
however the heck I do that I'm not dead
having a habit I happen to have an Abba
Dabba Dabba Dabba okay I finally managed
to navigate my way back up in the dark
very god damnit I hate that I hate the
jumping away from this [ __ ] mmm
all right back up a little bit more
don't make me jump again alright okay we
made it alright finally okay so just
walk in ah good okay we got water good I
need water
lamb you got that I was there nothing in
here besides the plan turn this really
all there was
oh yeah the inner endure grow bed the
big one I do need that I definitely 100%
need that okay that's good so we got
that and we got everything that we need
as of right now okay so that's good so
now officially we have absolutely
everything that we need to be able to
survive on a base near the Aurora which
is the next step in this journey because
there's some questions that need to be
answered over there we're not there yet
I've got just enough juice to get over
there and this is the last one
I've messed up badly
I've messed up badly this time it's been
two days since what happened we never
should have left this island I shouldn't
have listened to them we shouldn't have
gone so deep we're not wanted down there
they don't trust us I knew it and I
didn't say I could see it and they
couldn't and now they're stuck down
there and I'm up here alone
I deserve this they don't trust us who's
they who in the world is they who the
hell is he talking about here are their
natives on this planet and that's the
thing these people were shot down the
Aurora was shot down who is they who are
they
who's they I don't know but hopefully
we'll find out maybe not yet the game is
still in development but hopefully we
will find out who they so anyway thank
you everybody so much for watching let
me know what you thought down in the
comments below and as always I will see
you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]